they already had grogu maybe in some bat
classroom working on them and then when
you know little jake lloyd shows up in
the council chamber they're like
not another one please god now this
little
[ __ ] is evil wow
welcome back to new rock stars guys the
mandalorian season two
has been hinting at a dark turn for the
child
grogu so everyone who got a baby yoda
tattoo
is maybe thinking twice about that now
and everybody who named their kid
daenerys
well they already regret that i'm marina
mastros
and this is rogue theory the show that
brings you the nerdy hot takes on the
topics that you can't stop talking about
with me today to go rogue is new
rockstar's own jedi eric boss everybody
yes
oh hello hello i don't think i'm a jedi
anymore
uh i don't care what they say i walked
away from that order as soon as they
said i
couldn't get a piercing that was the
line that was a hard line and we are
lucky to have a writer and anastasia
enthusiast
laura siricool here as well yes hey
hey thanks for having me i'm so excited
and you're gonna make eric
look like a piece of [ __ ] just because
you know so much more than he does
and you don't have to work that hard i'm
already starting at like
par is is [ __ ] for me i think oh
guys and please give a very warm welcome
to
my friend pre new rockstars pre anything
pre anything guys pre anything
matt yeah hello everybody
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to be here we're having a good
time to be a lot of fun this is
matt's first time on new rockstars right
that's right
welcome to matt this is exciting to have
you on in the new rockstars cinematic
universe
it can be that's right this is a pretty
we got a lot to talk about on this one
i'm very excited about this
absolutely matt is right so chapter 14
of the mandalorian
ends with the artist formerly known as
baby yoda in the hands of moff gideon
and
force choking some stormtroopers like a
less cuddly version of the little guy
we've all grown to love
he's doing honestly a really good job of
it like he's like they're like little
puppets and he's just throwing them
against the wall
yeah yeah yeah maybe it's bad but you
guys when i was watching it i was like
which is like not what we want but from
what we've learned
in the series this is no average jedi
student grogu might
be anakin or luke level force powerful
and the show is clearly teasing us with
whether or not he's going to end up on
the light or the dark side so let's
assume the worst for today
let's do it because it is 2020 after all
so you guys each of you pitch me on how
grosgoo's transition to the dark side
will go down i want to start with eric
okay okay um so just for the sake of
argument today
i i love that we are assuming the worst
let us
also assume that we have been in the
darkest timeline the whole time yeah
because here's what i'm thinking right
now i think grogu may have
already been demonstrating the traits
of dark side tendencies from the
beginning
and that is why the jedi council was so
hesitant to train anakin as a jedi to
begin with they refused to make him a
jedi master
and why most other jedi didn't know
about grogu he could have been
kept away from the other jedi in the
temple as a precaution
because this little [ __ ] is evil
and they already had grogu maybe in some
back classroom working on them and then
when you know little jake lloyd shows up
in the council chamber they're like
not another one please god now yeah so
that could be why grogu now in the
mandalorian he's
hasn't been in jedi hands nor the empire
hands at the start of this show
he's just been like put him away
somewhere and that's why
maybe throughout the mandalorian we've
seen evidence of this right he force
choked cara dune
and that freaked us out uh and now he's
forced choking and thrashing around
these storm troopers
he ate these eggs he didn't know whether
they were fertilized or not he just
gobbled them up
so i think what's gonna happen i uh
think
grogu's dark side is going to fully
emerge
in the finale of the season the
mandalorian
as he watches a duel between mando and
moff gideon
and he's gonna fulfill that promise that
maf gideon said of you're likely to poke
an eye out with one of these things
and turn that dark saber on moff gideon
so he grows i think yeah he's just
he's watching this this uh climactic
duel go down
gideon gets the upper hand on mando uh
and then his hand starts to shake
the dark saber lifts out of his hand but
because grogu is such a badass for this
thing he can
keep it ignited as it turns back on him
you know kind of like
guns and x-men uh and it goes back and
it goes into his eye socket
now keep them alive be that specific
nobody made it i laugh because i'm
morbid like that i'm like oh that's good
yeah yeah do we give him a cybernetic
eye or is this he's dead
or is he just that's a that's a good
question matt because i don't know if i
want
gin carlos posito to die yet i do want
him to have some freak
injury but like we saw with fenik shan
she got some cybernetic abs
some steampunk you know there's bellows
going out coming out
uh and anakin like he suffered a far
worse fate one could argue
you know on the dunes of mustafar
so if he can come back from that i'm off
getting come back from this
um now but i don't think it's gonna end
there i think
that just like how the saber went into
ray's hand and the force awakens that
it's gonna go right into grosgu's hand
and then uh you know they're all gonna
be like okay kid
uh great hand it back to us bogatan's
gonna be like yes that's mine
that is family and uh grogan's just
gonna be like
and he is going to wield it on them
because he is freaking out he's got
uh the dark side flowing through him in
fact ahsoka is going to be like
goddammit i knew this was going to
happen
yeah you know she's going to be fighting
this kid but he's got it's like trying
to pitch for um
a batter who is too short he's gotten
straight range so she's gonna be like
yeah how do i get this thing it's gonna
be like dooku versus uh yoda all over
again
he's gonna be bouncing all over the
place eventually mando is going to be
like
enough and he's gonna have to give his
own life to show this child the meaning
of true selflessness and that
is gonna be the thing that wakes up
grogu from his
uh his evil state
his his uh caretaker in front of his
eyes
um now i i just think you know tommy and
i talked about this on on wikileaks last
week i think we could be setting up for
mando death
only because it is called the
mandalorian he
is a masked character and that
mandalorian could be
a disambiguous thing and refer to lots
of characters on this show
uh in his dying words he could say now
you are the mandalorian going forward
and it's like kind of a dying wish that
bogatan and ahsoka filled they become
like kind of co-caretakers
to the this child and bokeh tan
as the mandalorian as the heiress says
uh i will train him in the way this is
the way and ahsoka will promise to
prevent him from going
in her way the way of the jedi so that
would make the
mandalorian live on in the child and the
mandalorian live on in poketan
i mean that's great whoa that's great
man
yeah when you said uh gorgoo was gonna
be running around between legs i was
thinking benny hill music
just like really fun
mostly we want this to be a comedy yes
i know a lot of people are like no no
way they're going to kill off petro
pascal's character on this show
is that really who you identify with
some people say yes i think
it you need to keep grogu on the show he
is the face of the show
yeah you don't identify with lone walker
walker brooding mysterious i identify
with that
you know yeah i like that a lot
um i like that a lot eric for for that
reason and
because you're willing to take a risk
like you're saying like this is going
game of thrones
like style right like no character is
safe we could get rid of the mandalorian
right and
and there are other mandalorians on the
show that we could follow and it would
still be
like you said the name of the show i
also like that you made
um baby i'm still going to call him baby
hoda come on
sure yeah baby yoda's story fit
in with the prequels and the whole lore
pre-anakin like he existed before he was
dark before anakin came and that's the
reason
that they treated anakin the way that
they did because of him
which i like because it's not just oh we
have to make this make sense so we're
gonna throw it in here and it's part of
the
the the sequential things that have
already happened like
don't get any more depth or they don't
change in any way but
because of this the way you describe it
it actually gives everything a lot more
meaning
and more layers to it okay so eric you
get
uh two rogies and what they are is um
little sugar skulls little candies
um so you see you get them the up there
whoa
if you say anything that i don't like
then i'll just eat them
okay then you just eat more
totally candy um great who wants to go
next
okay so this is my theory that i have uh
of course
um we saw a little bit of the dark side
in um baby yoda i'm just gonna baby yeah
like if gorgeous really yeah i'm gonna
say yes
we saw a little bit of dark side and so
they look so good but i don't blame
him i think he was hiding when anakin
killed off all his friends
so i think he was hiding somewhere so i
don't blame him for being dark because
it's like oh my god all my friends are
murdered
so i feel like okay
he's a little bit upset and he's like
he's mad about that
so what i believe will happen there's
going to be a showdown between moff
gideon
with his with his dark saber and then um
mando with his spear i feel like maf
killian's gonna stab
din with his own uh uh spear and it's
gonna be in the tunnel
the spear comes off he falls he's going
to survive because a robo tummy
we got this
[Applause]
yeah that's great she's gonna have a
robo tummy so
i feel like that's foreshadowing that
you know that's a way that we could
save mando from mafia so baby yoda
thinks
that oh my god my dad my dad got like
stabbed oh no like and he
he dead and so
so i feel like okay that's when it's
gonna
break for him he's gonna force pick up
the spear
and stab and and kind of put it into
gideon
and then gideon's gonna fall i don't
know if gideon's gonna die or not
because you know
we never know and you have to use juan
carlo many times because he's amazing
he's amazing he needs to win that emmy
for once
and so i feel like he'll stab that and
then that will activate his blood
because they they already took his blood
so that's kind of like the
tea that they needed to make the clones
that they wanted
so and it creates like snoke
so i feel like that's the project that
they're using and we're gonna see that
the second season where we're gonna
see more of the clonings and the clones
get activated uh because baby yoda was
activated like the sith side came and it
kind of turned up sparked something
because it's mixed with palpatine
so oh so i feel like i feel like we're
basically going to see
how baby yoda activates the clones
uh the clones of snokes whoa that's sick
and baby yo that's gonna be tired he's
gonna pass out and then they're gonna
collect him and they're gonna be like oh
what are we going to do with this and so
that's how they're going to keep him for
the next season like alive
and not be dark side they're going to be
like oh [ __ ] he activated something we
need to figure this out so their next
season will be focused on
on preventing with the clones i love
that i love that because
in my head i see the scene
it's all it's not going to look like
this but in my head
they're tapping on the glass in that
it's like a couple episodes ago
they show the like clones that didn't
work and they're tapping on the glass
and they're like
oh we can't get these clothes to work
and then
moth getting has baby oda he turns to
the dark side he's like eyes glow red
they won't but in my head they do
and then as soon as baby ota turns to
the dark side all the clones are like
wow
and they all like turn on and wake up
yeah
and they all just know a bunch of eggs
they just go
get like nude snoke in the tank it's
just like in like turns
[Laughter]
that's so great um laura i'm going to
give you two
two rogies two little sugar skulls so
you can uh take them and eat them so i'm
keeping track of your guys's score
and are you are you eating the scores
i'm also eating them
so okay yeah eric you're one point down
okay matt what do you think all right
i'm very excited guys these are
both amazing theories by the way and i
love them i love them yeah all right so
hear me out
um they're pulling a lot from rebels
matt i won't hear you out
okay well thanks guys that's been fun
i'm kidding i'm kidding uh so they've
been playing a lot from rebels and you
know the clone wars series and
everything like that so i think
that it's gonna be thrawn is gonna be
the one who actually
turns uh grogu to the dark side and
here's why
okay here is why so i'm kind of
following the same kind of formula that
you guys have talked about as well it's
going to be
you know right now the the maf gideon
has already begun the process
of turning groga to the dark side by by
having him lash out in fear and anger
those are key elements
to uh you know to to latching out with
that kind of
power so he he's already begun the
process
you know mando and his crew are gonna
come rescue grogu
uh there is gonna be a super cool
showdown with the besker spear
and the dark saber and mando and um i'm
off gideon
and they're going to be throwing down
probably they're going to be lava it's
going to be really cool
yeah it's going to be really cool but
den is going to lose he'll probably get
stabbed and he's going to be left on the
floor
uh and and before moth getting gives the
final blow
uh grogu is going to force choke moff
gideon and
almost kill him but mando is going to
step in
as a fatherly figure because he doesn't
want his newborn new child i guess
to kill somebody so he's like this is
not the way
no there's a better way this is the way
this is not the way
yes so so he will leave he's going to
leave moff gideon but he's going to be
defeated and they're going to he's going
to get the child amanda's going to get
the child they're going to leave with
grogu
um but but then
we're going to see a post-credits scene
where moff gideon is actually talking to
the big bad in charge of all these old
star destroyers
and that is going to be of thrawn
because where did throng go after
rebels i think he's been planning this
this whole time uh and thrawn's going to
be like
very interesting he's going to like what
he sees he's going to like the progress
and it's like he's progressing well
uh which leads to the next season
because thrawn thinks in order to fully
turn into the dark side
he sees the relationship between mando
and and grogu
that he thinks that they need to build a
tighter bond so he can like rip mando
away from him
which will fully have him lash out even
more so i think this is just
still the beginning steps and at that
point that's when thrawn's gonna step in
and like
uh seduce him with the powers of you
know the dark side and stuff like that
so
that's why i think it's going to turn
wow that's cool yeah
i love the thrawn being the uh the man
behind the curtain behind the man behind
the curtain
yeah right right i think it's really
cool and i think that
i'm gonna say this for the next argument
never mind
thrawn is a blue skinned red eyed dude
he was an imperial
admiral and apparently he's like a daddy
dude like not like a daddy daddy but
looks like
a daddy daddy you know
he said he's a hot daddy he's a hot
daddy people want like fast bender to
play him
you google like daddy
people are like ooh daddy he's good yeah
he's a blue daddy man
yeah for real wow okay john you must
keep that part in
you gotta see the comment in the
comments
like oh my god he is the best sleepless
vest
like this news reboot of samurai jack
where he's like
all rugged and like ripped you know
that's like wrong
yeah he looks like a member of uh duran
duran's like roadie crew yeah
yeah it's like a sexy blue man group
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so everyone's like oh
turn me turn me down
the dark side that's so funny
um okay great matt i like that it makes
it seem like or it makes it goes back
and it retroactively says like okay
everything that moff getting has been
doing
has been sanctioned by thrawn even if
moff gideon didn't know his exact plan
like
he sees like okay this kid is turning
he's not just using him
for his blood which is like kind of
something that a lower ranking person
would
would want to do and just think like
short term like oh he's
he's we just want his blood like there's
nothing else to be had from him
but like a person who's planning for the
future like what eric was saying like if
he did want to build his own army like
he would keep him around because he's
more of an asset that way
so that makes sense to me yeah and also
he's a blue daddy so
blue daddy baby we want him involved
we want him involved um this new fleet
refers to him as thrawn daddy
yeah yeah everyone calls him thrawn
daddy
oh my god i can't where have i been
where have i been
if you google it you'll see the fan art
it's amazing i'm
going to do that right now matt for
introducing me to
to thrawn daddy you get three
rogies there you go thank you oh my gosh
[Applause]
all right um uh now before we continue
with the rest of the episode
uh i'm gonna take the wheel here to talk
about some people who helped us make
this episode starting with our friends
at me
undies everything's a little tougher in
2020 including the holidays we'll carve
out some me time and
soften the holiday stress by giving
gifts from our friends
at me undies there micro modal is not
only super soft but breathable light
impossibly cozy get all your gifting
done from home and gift
new undies pj sets slippers and
everything else
you need to have a stress-free and
comfortable holiday i recently
got a pair of their lounge pants and
they are the perfect winter indoor wear
like luxuriously soft and comfy i'm
basically a professional
lounger now and we're getting paid to
lounge thanks me undies
uh and you can gift a membership with me
undies gift card their membership is a
subscription that sends new pairs right
to their door
so they never have to run out of undies
again with site-wide savings and
exclusive sales they automatically pay
less for
everything meundies also has their
problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats no questions
to get your 15 off your first order and
free shipping
go to meetundies.com rockstars that's me
undies.com
rockstars we also want to thank our
friends at manscape for helping us make
this episode look
even if you're a 50 year old child like
grogu you got some fur
in places all over that body and you
shouldn't have to cover it in a weird
little baby robe
uh some of us feel like babies our
entire lives until we get some
uncomfortable fur and that's where
manscape comes in
and saves you because manscaped has the
lawnmower 3.0 trimmer it helps
prevent nicks and cuts so you don't end
up looking like
you got into a darksaber fight that
nickton snagged and cut things he didn't
want cut
the new lawnmower 3.0 is waterproof with
advanced skin safe technology even has a
light
to help you shave everywhere so you
don't have to use
the light of a lightsaber when you're
doing it it's not safe to put that in
certain places
they've also got the new weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer to
make sure your mustache stays nice and
trim and looking fine
just like grief kargas does because you
know that guy
knows how to escape now if you have uh
smelly feet manscaped
can also help with that they got a foot
duster foot deodorant made to fight odor
on even the funkiest of feet if you want
to smell good everywhere the refined
cologne by manscaped is a clean and
fresh scent designed
for the refined gentleman get 20 off and
free shipping with the code rogue theory
at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use the code rogue theory be sure to
join the manscaped movement
and keep that hair from grow gooey
[Music]
there you go stupid uh and lastly we
want to thank our friends at expressvpn
no matter which
side of the is i heard a christmas movie
or not debate you stand on
one thing is definitely true die hard
isn't on netflix in the united states
tis the season to be thankful though you
can access the netflix library
where die hard is actually available
with expressvpn
i did just that to access german netflix
which is ironic because the villains of
that movie are
totes german but they love that because
it is on their netflix
it's super easy all you got to do you
fire up the expressvpn app and you
change your location
refresh netflix and that's it it thinks
you're in germany and you get access to
that stuff
expressvpn changes your ip address so
you can control where sites think you're
located
choose from almost 100 different
countries just
think about all the netflix libraries
you can get access to
and of course it's not just for die hard
you can use expressvpn to access
thousands of new titles on netflix
disney plus bbc iplayer you name it
expressvpn is ridiculously fast for
streaming movies
there's never any buffering and it
always streams in 4k or hd
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices you can watch what you want
on the go or on the big screen yippee
kaye
and if you visit my special link right
now at expressvpn.comrogue
you can get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free on a one year
package
support this show watch what you want
and protect yourself at
expressvpn.com rogue good job eric
thanks what's up well said okay
just for right now i'm in japan my
computer's in japan i changed my ip
address
okay um okay we are on to
our second topic of rogue theory so
teased at the end of the first episode
of this season boba fett showed up in
all his badass bounty hunter glory in
last week's episode
reclaimed his papa's armor and now is in
the grogu rescue crew
with mandel fenix and and maybe others
did you guys see that tweet i don't know
who it's from
we'll have to like find it to credit
that person but they said like the
mandalorian is just a show about a guy
who can't stop making best friends
i did see that he's literally literally
every shonen jump protagonist
out there i saw that
that's right yeah so boba fett's
character is really
one of only a handful to span both the
prequel series and
the original trilogy so you have to
imagine we're gonna get
to see a lot more of him before he goes
away like we would be screaming at our
tvs and throwing things
at disney at disney's ghost i guess his
ghost
um so you guys now that we have him
now that we have him back and we got to
see explosions happen behind him
and he was like doing all kinds of
tricks and we had the laser thing that
comes down he was like
it was so cool what are we going to see
in the future with boba fett what do you
guys think matt
y'all
[Laughter]
this one's i'm going to get some enemies
here
boba fett is going to die oh no
this is the end we're seeing the end of
his story right now he didn't get
everything i just said
not true well we i think we still
because i think the series is
it's going to start from where he left
off in the sarlacc pit
to now and it's gonna fill that gap and
this is his ending
we see him like like look look and i'm
gonna explain just how it happens to you
i'm explaining just how it happens
i gotta preface it by saying look boba
fett well it's just a
let's be real boba fett was just a grunt
dude he was just like a grunt he was
hired by the imperials you know i mean
like he didn't really do anything that
cool
unless you're playing like the boba fett
video game which might have been jango
fett
i don't remember and i don't care all i
know is that i'm not going to call you
up thank you
it might have been jango fett but i
don't remember all i know is that like
this dude outside of like
in like in the main canon he hasn't
really done anything that cool he looks
cool
he looks dope but like like you put him
next to dan and den is such a more
like fleshed out character we care about
him like he's not even mandalorian dude
he's a clone a jango vet who's like
not mandalorian he's like a faux man
delorean or something yeah yeah and they
explained that whole thing too because
he was like why would i give you your
armor back when you not
my [ __ ] yeah dude so i think this is
like and i'm gonna explain exactly how
it's because this is him going out in a
blaze of glory he's badass he's getting
his moment
now and we're gonna see him being a
badass up to this moment but
it's they're gonna be pressed down by
moff gideon's dark troopers
on on their ship uh they were like oh no
what are we gonna do and he's gonna
think back he's like
oh man this guy's trying to save his his
basically adopted son
i gotta i gotta give him a chance i give
him a chance so he's gonna be like
hey take the slave one his [ __ ] he's
like this
the ship's yours and he's gonna walk out
with like grenades
activate him all over it and walk over
and destroy close the door behind him
and it's gonna blow himself up with all
the dark troopers
and he's gonna give mando mando his the
slave one because uh his ship got blown
up
yeah so he's gonna have to slave one and
fly around with in that
uh and then and then as i said before
hamaf gideon right i'm off gideon
yeah he he does in my version he doesn't
die he almost dies a stroke and they
they leave
but because the boba fett blows up moff
gideon's gonna get that freaking
mandalorian armor and he's gonna mock up
his own thing and he's gonna be like an
even bigger threat in season three
i know right now so many people hate me
and that's okay
that's okay not here buddy this is a
safe space
no yeah the second half of the episode
no one's watching
it's true though the only person i ever
give [ __ ] to is eric
this is that that's great i actually
like that because even though
even though people are gonna be mad at
you right they're gonna be like there's
no way they brought him back just to
have him die in the season blah blah
but you fix that because you let him go
out in a blaze of glory
yeah and he's gonna be the only reason
that
mando lives and and baby yoda escapes so
like
they can't be that mad thank you thank
you guys
and like i said this is just a take so
it's okay
it's okay i have a different favorite
character it's okay
uh matt i'm giving you uh an additional
rogi
it's going in your pile so far you're in
the lead
um so laura you can take that lead away
what do you think first off
matt how dare you second you
how dare you anyway i was ready for this
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna give uh
boba fett
a different a different um ending
because he is my favorite drink
um so this man has been through
so much okay he got like taken over by a
sarlacc pit he lost his stuff to jawas
so i feel like this character just needs
to rest a little bit
but also this is din's story we're not
going to see
him come along with the in the adventure
because this is dinosaur he is the
mandalorian
so i believe that at first he's going to
be like basically the child
they're going to he's going to be like
oh i'm going to just rest and everything
but because of my clone theory he's
gonna see the clones and get triggered
because he is from he is an unaltered
clone
and he was among clones and so he's
gonna have flashbacks
of like his time when he was training
with the clones
of his father he is gonna be triggered
to kind of either
destroy the clones that the empires are
creating the empire is creating
or free them because he understands
he understands that so what we know wow
yeah so i feel like he's gonna we're
gonna go with their separate ways
so i feel like bo canton's gonna do her
mandalore stuff um din is
is gonna have the child with his robot's
tummy and try to figure out
figure out what he robo tell me he's
going to figure out what he's going to
do with this child to kind of prevent it
from
fully going sith like he always makes
friends but they always go their own way
and then we come back together so i feel
like that's gonna be with boba fett
where he's like
okay mando you figured out our our
connection thing i owe you is done i got
you the child
we good but my task now is to help the
clones or free the clones or destroy the
clones
because you know cloning is bad i love a
leftist socialist liberation agenda
free them all and then he dies
okay so yourself then how dare you
anything about like liberating
a bunch of people who are under the rule
of someone else like
marina maybe they they are more
comfortable being under the subjugation
is this not more comfortable
isn't this not the better way as loki
would say
to be uh yeah
i'm making i realize i'm making the
argument that they want to be in cages
no one wants
you know until uh order 66 made them all
crazy
but you know what uh this is like this
is like going
deep but uh i think it's either pla i
think it's plato's
plato or socrates it's about the the
story of the cave somebody in here yeah
plato's allegory of the cave and then
socrates was his student
yeah so do you wanna i don't know
literally i have a master's degree in
rhetoric and i'm supposed to know that
and i don't remember
but do you want to live in the cave or
do you want to realize that there's a
world outside the cave
and go out and you know i could some
people when they hear that story they
want to stay in the cave
that's right it's cypher in the matrix
right that delicious piece of filet
mignon
ignorance is voice baby yeah exactly
he's giving them a choice
and i like that he gets his own path he
gets his own story yeah they can't
afford to hit
morrison for any longer
that's great i'm giving you an
additional rogi
um eric what say you oh okay um
well first off uh matt how dare you
and and also so second off laura how
dare you
reena also how dare you marina uh
for bringing politics into this uh
second half of the show
have you ever met me have you ever seen
star wars too
no no i'm just really good at guessing
what these things are about yeah
he never has never so here's my favorite
boba fett
i think uh in the short term maybe in
season three
boba fett is going to help boca tan
liberate mandalore that seems like
uh an alliance that makes sense they
both have a mutual interest to liberate
that planet
however i don't think the alliance will
last
boba fett is too much of a loner bo
katan is probably too stubborn she's
going to want to rule mandalore the way
she thinks as the heiress
she should but that's going to be like
what are you talking about like they
come from different clans right and if
you go
to this django fat comic that they
referenced in this recent episode
uh the death watch which is who uh
bogatan was originally with
hunted down the clan that jango fett was
brought up in they
called themselves a true mandalorians
they were on concord dawn the death
watches from concordia from the
mandalorian civil war
they fled to the moon of concordia
concordon is another planet in the
mandalore system
and they chased down jaster who was
jango fett's mentor
you know you could imagine boba fett
still kind of having a sore spot about
that history and i think
those that old history the fact that was
brought up in this episode i think is
going to be a wedge point
between them and i think going forward
it's far more interesting to have
conflict rather than these characters
just live in peace in their system after
they liberate the planet right
it's i hope they go the game of thrones
model of like yes we helped each other
sack the capital but now that we
are co-owning it what are now the new
rivalries and new
conflicts between us uh so i would love
to see
uh kind of a new clan of mandalorians
form under boba fett's leadership that
is kind of
in this cold war with boko tan going
forward
that creates kind of a conflict between
them and then it builds up to be
a battle of the bose a bow bowl
boba fett and uh yeah we see those two
fighting season four or something like
that
and then for peace boba fett dies to
bring bridges again
how dare you watch the second half of
the episode
eric i like that because you're giving a
long-term direction for the show
and i mean like long-term like warren
clans is like okay we're invested in
both of them and we need to see how both
of them turn out
um so you're not just being like okay
season two
it's like okay this is how we make this
show last because there's no way disney
plus is giving it up because it's such a
success yeah so
yeah this gives it some legs and and a
direction to go
um so i'm getting legs for days and legs
for days
uh an additional uh reggie
okay uh matt is still in the lead with
eric you have three laura you have three
so it's anyone's game
uh and we are about to to decide the
winner because
anybody can switch rankings with our
round of rogue questions
so here we go question number one alfred
molina
alfred molina is coming back as dr
octopus in spider-man 3
with some sources saying kirsten dunst
and andrew garfield
are also returning so the question is
what's the worst possible way they could
use these characters
because that's a great question this is
2020. and we are go
we're going dark side and we're going
down i'll say
the worst way they could use those three
actors is uh they
are featured in the movie but it's
on-screen uh
archive footage from other movies like
ned is watching like uh indiana
and watching um jumanji and watching
hacksaw ridge
and then they just appear on screen for
just a second but they still get paid
for that that's great i'm putting a
rogue in your pile there it goes
yes um for me i think the worst way they
can do it
is like they try to do this weird clone
conspiracy saga like to do in the comics
but like instead of actually making
clones of the people inside of the
marvel
cinematic universe it's like it's like
slightly different clones that didn't
quite work
you know what i mean so it's like oh
[Laughter]
on hollywood boulevard who are in the
costumes but like they're not quite
oh yeah little costumes yeah smelly
joker
yeah okay so i think the worst way
to use them we make all these
announcements about using
um andrew garfield kristen dunst and
alpha molina and this is how they're
going to use them oh let's offer melina
oh it's kristen dunst andrew garfield
and that's it that's the worst coffee
and then leave yeah it's just like a
flash like oh alpha molina looks up like
oh what was that
and then that's it what if they were
anticipating so much
we're like we're just like saying like
and that's it
like they come in and they order a
coffee and then to camera they're like
yeah yeah and then they leave hmm
[Laughter]
someone has a dream about all three of
them and then wakes up
oh my gosh yeah oh my god okay there's
even an anime like spider-hams in there
for some reason
[Laughter]
please don't do it but that would be the
worst you know what just do who framed
roger rabbit style
yes but spiderman okay question number
two the producers of godzilla vs
kong are reportedly upset that their
movie is going to be released on
hbo max so the question is how do you
can you tell that i didn't write these
questions how do you think godzilla and
king kong
feel about it how do you think they feel
about their movie being released on hbo
max
so godzilla and king kong how do they
feel
about the fact that their movie is gonna
be released on hbo max
that is the question i think they're
going to be really extremely angry
because okay the subscription to hbo max
is so expensive
so they're going to be so angry at that
because that should be expensive
and they're going to sign with netflix
instead
they stomp their way over because this
is so much better they get better award
seasons
anyway yeah i put a rogue in your pile
thank you
um you know what i think that they're
not gonna be mad about
it airing on a streaming platform
they've had their premieres y'all
they've had like 50 plus years of
premiere
so i think they might be a little numb
to that but and to their car they might
be mad about like
like am i going to get those residuals
because that is in there and they're sag
after contract after all
uh so like like they're going to be
upset about like not getting those
residuals
that's right that's right that's right
so they gotta figure that out they want
their paper they yeah
[Laughter]
i think godzilla and king kong are just
going to like text each other
and they don't know what hb max is like
are these
it's just hbo do i still get it and then
they check it out and then they both
watch the undoing and they're like what
is undoing
why did nicole kidman i thought she was
the killer
like yeah why did they have her cross
the street at the scene of the crime
if that had nothing to do with it why
did she have a helicopter at the end
that was seriously the final shot why
all the red herrings
how did he know to use a dishwasher if
he's 10 years old
and then it's just somebody give the
lawyer a golden globe
yeah i want to be on that thread because
everything you have said i have seen
yeah
it's so good that's a great thread
that show makes no sense but i watched
it
i watched the whole thing two inches
from my screen i was like what's gonna
happen
i am and you're great hugh grant's like
uh he's you know he's so trusting
usually and now it's like
did he he got me yeah you got me he got
me
that whole show got me there was 12
different better theories
i had for that show than what it ended
up being i won't say what it ended up
being but um
guess what the winner is it was a tie
but because matt is my
personal friend he win
oh my gosh thank you so much for not
killing me for my boba fett statement
no you only get support um thanks man
yes and and congratulations on your
first time being on the show
so you get to win because you're my
favorite and also
suck it eric uh
guys that's it that's it for this
episode of rogue theory so thank you to
our guest thank you to laura thank you
to eric thank you to matt
thank you murray thank you of course of
course guys follow eric
uh on social media follow matt matt
what's your handle at the
matt acevedo and laura what's your
handle at l
siri cool siri cool yes follow them both
uh follow me at marina masters and guys
do not forget to subscribe to the rogue
theory podcast because you will get that
before it comes out on youtube
stay tuned to the youtube channel though
for this and other shows
follow us on twitter at new rockstars we
are out there and we
are doing it yeah we're doing it
[Music]
blue daddy blue daddy daddy daddy
you won't regret it the long black
luxurious hair waving in the wind yeah
that's right
blue where it counts
[Laughter]
no blue chew needed for thrawn daddy
[Music]
you